tip number two okay number two there are
only two screenwriting rules yeah the so
I've got in my book here even got
labeled for you rule number one is write
a script it looks like a script
Oh Jerry talked about right so if it
looks like a novel it's not a script
it's going in the garbage so if it looks
like a script you at least got past the
first game because there are a lot of
scripts that come in that don't look
like scripts they're getting like I
seriously get when I was doing reading
for a producer I was sent the script
read that was three hundred and twelve
pages
I'm not reading a 312 page script it's
not happening it doesn't look like a
script right off the bat so as long as
it looks like a script like say even the
formatting you can have a little tweaks
here and there as long as it still looks
like a script and number two write a
script that feels like a movie
preferably a good movie if you're
obviously ranked TV then it would be
right see what it feels like a TV
episode if you are writing this big
lengthy thing that feels like it should
be a novel you're getting into character
mine's all this other stuff it's not a
movie anymore if you're telling me
something that's just us sitting you're
having a conversation this is great for
a YouTube video I'm not gonna watch the
whole movie of me sitting there talking
to you well like even documentaries you
they're cutting away to other stuff
right like other things are happening
then just to be able talk to each other
so it needs to look like a movie look
like a script and it needs to feel like
a movie bonus points it's a good movie
like that okay so don't write war and
peace
oh yeah and submit it back see ya don't
don't try to have an eight part series
yeah it because if it's if it's a short
so I've been asked a question from
people on like Facebook and stuff where
they've DM me and asking like okay how
do you how can I tell if it's a short or
a feature or show okay if you can tell
the entire story in like 20 minutes or
less and be done with it it's a short if
you can tell the thing but if it's gonna
take at least half an hour to tell it
and you can have it done in like three
hours and then that's it like we never
have to see these characters again like
it's a feature but if it's too short
fleshing out the
feature to get there if it's you know
like a little bit it's three hours try
to pull back a little bit to make it a
feature but it's a feature if you can
tell it you know in a couple of hours
but if it's something that could go on
and on forever it's probably a
television series you know if I made a
flash like if I'm going to comic books
if I have the flash TV series versus the
the flash movie that may or may not ever
even happen now with Ezra Miller those
are gonna be two very different flash
stories because in one they're gonna be
telling the story between like an hour
and a half two and a half hours the
other one we're already what six seasons
in and it's still going we can have
episodic and keep going you know they're
gonna be two very different stories to
tell sort of thing so yes that is so
that's that's the thing with the with it
being cinematic is figuring out where
does it fall in line is it short is the
feature is it a TV show is it a book is
it like a is it a comic book series is
it a poem you know they're graphic all
these different things have different
sort of world and guidelines to them
because if your story but it means it
needs to go around the story you want to
tell so if the story you want to tell if
you could keep telling it over and over
and over with different things it's
probably a TV series if you're gonna
tell me this is a synced little story
that's cool and has like a couple
different a plot be lousy plot but it's
only take you two hours to tell it it's
feature so keeping those in mind is how
to figure out you know where your story
lies among all of the medium that there
is to create in it might be a painting I
don't know exactly you cannot trash-talk
the field you want to be a part of yes
[Music]
this is one of the things so a big
reason I wrote this book to begin with
was because of seeing people on the
Facebook screenwriting groups asking the
same questions over and over this
particular tip was seeing of huge faux
pas that a lot of writers do where
they're like I'm writing this because
there's nothing good in Hollywood there
are no good move
anymore well why are if you're
announcing that to the world like why do
you want to make movies if there's
nothing good like what is the point of
you going into a field where you think
everything out there is garbage why do
you want to be a part of this and why
are you gonna tell people that you think
it's all garbage to begin with you know
it's so yeah don't don't trash this is a
field you want to be in don't start
trash-talking other people's work don't
try to talk other people who are working
in the industry that you may or may not
ever work with because this is a small
town and that gets around
so safer for politics oh yeah
[Laughter]
you